[Music]
all right never really thought I would
make this video but here we are dear
YouTube first of all I love you guys and
there's a lot of things you guys do
really well especially for creators that
no one else does well but there's also
plenty of things that you guys could do
better
so YouTube you've been an amazing place
for creators and video makers obviously
to be for the better part of the last
decade even more than that and it's been
awesome but there's also been this like
constant background tic this little rash
of things that just sort of wither away
at the creators trust in the platform
some faster than others now with me
luckily you've missed me with a lot of
that stuff like this is a tech channel
so pretty PG content nothing super
violent or graphic or anything like that
so I didn't have any problems with
monetization there was no ad pocalypse
here nothing crazy but you know the
phrase the straw that broke the camel's
back
obviously this camel's back is not
broken but there have been plenty of
straws and just plenty of weird head
scratchers here's a little background
for those who don't know on the latest
straw the thumbnails experiment so
youtuber tweeted at YouTube pretty
recently asking why it appeared that
their custom thumbnails seemed to be
broken for some of their viewers YouTube
replied to that youtubers tweet we are
running a small experiment where point 3
percent of viewers will see an
auto-generated thumbnail instead of your
custom thumbnail we are not removing the
ability to create your custom thumbnail
but we hope to gain insight on
auto-generated thumbnails for the future
wait see you just what so ok YouTube I
feel like I'm I might even have like a
more level-headed response than than
many other people I try to see both
sides of it I went to business school I
get that this is a business decision you
want to make auto-generated thumbnails
better for the millions of people that
use it so you got to run some
experiments do some a be testing get
some results and then implement useful
changes I get it this is how you evolved
this is how you make YouTube calm better
for people but you got to tell people
about this unless I tell people I don't
mean a little post in the Google product
forum that
literally less than a thousand people
have ever seen I don't mean a YouTube
video on a channel with 60,000
subscribers that less than 10,000 people
have ever seen because it turns out when
you run a small experiment that only
affects 0.3 percent of your 1.9 billion
monthly active users for a few weeks you
can expect that change to affect more
than 5 million people so YouTube when
you run experiments like this which I'm
sure you do all the time without even
telling people but when you do two
things one tell everyone and to make it
optional like here's the thing YouTube
actually I really liked that little
forum post I think it was well detailed
it explained everything it was timely
and I love the little creator insider
channel actually giving us like a video
look maybe talking to a person who's
involved with these experiments and
technically they do their job of
informing people of the changes that are
gonna happen before they happen it shows
that you're aware that you should be
giving us the heads up but clearly
almost nobody saw it right so when I say
tell everyone put it on the homepage or
if that's too drastic which I think it
is put it in the creator studio that you
know we check every single day and then
when I say make it optional I know again
I can be tough but I really think this
kind of stuff should be either opt-in or
opt-out testing I think opt-in is tough
because not a lot of people will log in
and opt-in and you won't really get
those massive millions of people for the
sample size you need for your testing so
I think opt out is the way to go you
tell us about these things you're going
to be implementing and if it comes
across our dashboard and there's
something we don't like
then we uncheck the box and we opt out
so ok if we have to redo this whole
thumbnails thing with my two little
nuggets of advice here's how it will go
down so you work at YouTube and you want
to make improvements to auto-generated
thumbnails which the vast majority of
the millions of hours of video uploaded
to YouTube constantly will use
auto-generated thumbnails maybe working
on some image recognition maybe thrown
in some AI it's 2018 that makes sense I
get it so you make improvements great
you need to run an experiment and you
need some guinea pigs so as the
experiment is about to go live for your
millions of guinea pigs or your 0.3% of
users you whip up a nice little blog
post that details everything that's
about
happen how will effect the site how long
it will last maybe even toss that
embedded YouTube video in there with
people who are actively working on it
because there are people whose
livelihoods actually depend on changes
on the site then in the creator studio
in a new labs section or experimental
features box or whatever you want to
call it up at the top is this most
recent one thumbnail experiments with a
link to that blog post in the video for
everyone to see and a box to uncheck if
we want to opt out maybe even reward
people for not opting out most people
who just use YouTube casually don't
really look into the creator studio so
they're part of your experiment they're
just gonna browse like normal boom
that's your data collection that's
everything but then there are youtubers
who literally only upload custom
thumbnails they rely on custom thumbnail
some of them even pay for the creation
of custom thumbnails for their Channel
so they'll see this blog post and
naturally go you know what I think I'm
gonna opt out of this experiment that's
obviously going to hurt my business and
then at the end of the day thanks to the
communication both sides everyone wins
so just my point here YouTube is to err
on the side of over communication
especially with your creators I know it
seems weird for a creator on YouTube to
complain to YouTube but usually you've
erred on the side of under communication
and that's honestly the main crux of why
people get disappointed or mad once in a
while I'm sure you'll need to do some
experiments where you need everyone
involved and you can't opt out and
you'll gray out that little box and it's
just people will get mad just because
that's the way they are but at least
they'll know when it's over because the
information is right there in the
creator studio they check every day we
just want to know we just want to feel
like we are somewhat in control in some
way and part of that is just knowing
what's going on so I see you guys are
YouTube's already adding all these
useful actually really interesting
thoughtful things to the creative studio
beta I'm sure this would fit right in
along with those things so that's it
hopefully that sums up my point well
maybe if you agree with me you can share
this video feel free to share it with
other creators or with people at YouTube
for now that's been it thanks for
watching talk to you the next one peace